je me rends compte que je peux plus
bouger mes jambes j'ai pas me déplacer
je n'arrive pas à me relever
il se passe un truc est en fait j'ai un
black out pendant un certain temps je
pas combien de temps exactement d'un
petit black-out 12,1 en conséquence m
pendant ce temps là et
zarate course sur la dernière fois et
voilà ou non je pensais qu'à ça
pendant longtemps rock
[Musique]
13 novembre journée classique retrouve
mes maîtres de bons potes saoud et
françois devant la salle du bataclan
en fait c'est à ce moment là qu'on a
commencé à entendre
comme des ballons qui éclatait et en
fait ces ballons qui éclataient
c'étaient les premières balles qui
étaient tirés dans l'arrière de la salle
on allume les infos et effectivement à
ce moment là on voit ce qui est en train
de se passer
vous avez quelques minutes déjà à
comprendre qu'en fait il est bien là bas
et balazs et je pense que c'est la nuit
la plus longue de l'histoire qui n'est
pas bon pour moi en tout cas très
personnellement il ya un mouvement de
foule
je moi je me fais
je suis touché quasiment immédiatement
sait pas très bien quoi faire dans ces
moments là du coup donc moi je prends le
participe passé un coup de fil à pierre
de voir si ça répond pas et si ça répond
pas en gros je me dis surtout je
rappelle plus parce que si il ya un
téléphone qui fait du bruit si machin on
bosse un peu tendre les terroristes etc
et donc créer plus de dix cas qu'autre
chose comme à côté de moi il y avait un
mec est une meuf qui était l'un à côté
de l'autre la fini se lève pour partir
et le mec reste puisque lui il est
blessé au niveau de la jambe et au
moment où elle la meuf par elle mais ça
demain à lui dans la mienne est en fait
c'est lui qui m'a tenus mais réveillé
pendant jusqu'à ce que les
les médecins et pompiers viennent nous
chercher et du coup et c'est des moments
qui sont vraiment
notamment parce qu'en fait on n'a pas
justement la personne en face pour
savoir comment il a réagi et du coup moi
le moment où j'ai vu pierre bonjour je
rentre dans la chambre d'hôpital et où
je vois pierre je sais je sais en fait
je sais que ça va bien se passer
quelque part c'est bizarre de dire ça
mais je sais que ça va bien se passer
quand j'arrive en confiance et par an
évidemment aux parents que je connais
ses parents et je me dirige vers son
père et du beau jeu le diable en fonte
et marianne un peu bizarre jetez un oui
effectivement c'était pas forcément bons
termes mais peu importe du coup en vie
et elle a tellement aimé voir ce moment
ni rihanna a été assez a été assez
dingo parce qu'en gros tous que c'est
vachement marqué parce que en gros elle
a dit non mais c'est super pierre est en
vie pierre et la pierre est au top
machin et moi j'étais là au clic on voit
si elle trouve ça va du coup ok on y
voit les premiers jours à l'hôpital
c'est le sait un peu pour moi parce que
lui sur la prépa trop super merci mais
du coup c'est quand même un peu un
moment way important parce que parce
qu'on essaye un peu dévaluée l'échelle
de l'engagement contre on est d'ailleurs
je crois que maman lui a dit assad et
lui a dit aussi très vite après l'avoir
rencontré aussi ici en fait elle voulait
partir elle pouvait partir on est hyper
heureux que tu sois là mais en fait si
tu as le moindre doute
enfin fait-on fais ta vie dans ce truc
là quoi que ce soit avec nous un peu à
côté ou ou ailleurs mais ne se sent pas
prisonnière en fait j'ai bien réfléchi
et je me suis un peu dit ok je suis
prête à y aller quoi quoi qu'il se passe
mais je dis enfin j'aurais été prêt à y
aller même si
il avait eu par exemple je sais pas son
tempérament ou son mental altéré donc
fait quelque part quand on sait qu'on
est prêt à y aller pour ça on se dit ok
mais finalement un fauteuil france est
pas dramatique quoi on n'est pas
rassurante que voilà il yal interne qui
est sur place qui lui faire un
diagnostic est donc là il me dit assez
sèchement vous rend marchera plus donc
la petite claque
physiquement je ressens jusqu'ici bon
sous les pectoraux en fait sous cette
zone là je ne sens plus
chaud froid j'ai plus de sensibilité
j'espère que bouger les membres qui sont
dessous il ya une aide psychologique à
ce moment là une psychologue que je vais
une fois par semaine quelque chose comme
ça et
en fait moi ça ne sert à rien enfin n'y
avait pas de besoin plus que ça pour moi
d'en parler puisque encore une fois j'ai
pas de souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
j'ai pas de bruit j'ai pas d'odeur jeu
pas de
j'ai pas de vision j'ai rien vu de ce
qui s'est passé quand on est un peu
extérieur à tous à quelque part on se
dit toujours que les gens qui étaient en
direct dans la salle c'est beaucoup plus
dur pour eux des goûts donc on n'a pas
le droit de se plaindre et ça a été ma
réaction pendant très longtemps mais
mais effectivement enfin je pense qu'il
faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya des
familles derrière et que et que cette
attente cela en fait enfin c'est quand
même c'est pas drôle quoi c'est vraiment
des moments qui sont je sais que c'est
un doux euphémisme voilà mais du coup il
ya des trucs qui reste enfin moi je lui
les sirènes de pompiers pendant des mois
des fins même d'ailleurs encore presque
des années j'ai entendu des sirènes des
pompiers en fait dès que j'entendais
aussi à tout prix dans la rue j'étais
vraiment mal
il ya un moment de gros gros mâle
l'habitude de voir deux blessés
forcément si tu te retrouves et de
situations handicap surtout que ça
décape coûte probablement tout c'est que
tous regardé tout avis et c'est
difficile et pierre c'est vrai qu'on
voyait tous deux les parts que sa force
c'était deux semaines de son entourage
et donc on commence à discuter en disant
que quelque part on aimerait bien passer
le reste de notre vie ensemble qua non
pour la demande en mariage on est allé
se faire un resto dans paris france a
été une demande plutôt dream est simple
c'est même pas mis à genoux quand on met
le mec ça la connaît
[Musique]
on était trop content de ne faire ça te
fait on fait avec tout mon copain
familles et tous qui vous avait super
entouré jusque là on était content tu
vas leur offrir un bon moment de fête
tout changement c'est un peu une double
fête parce que c'était à la fois leur
mariage c'était c'était génial mais en
plus c'était un peu le j'ai pas comment
dire mais une forme de pas de victoire
mais c'était aussi faire un pied de nez
à la vie et se dire voilà on est là et
enfin voilà tout le monde être heureux
et c'est cool quoi
en juillet 2017 j'ai rencontré michael
jeremiasz qui est champion paralympique
de tennis est en fête
lui a créé une association avec sa femme
et son frère qui s'appelle comme les
autres et l'idée de cet assaut c'est de
permettre à des blessés de la moelle
épinière de découvrir en fait qu'il peut
faire plus que ce qu'ils pensent en fait
ce qui est assez marrant c'est que c'est
ces jours là ils sont volontairement
on n'a pas le temps de partir avec un
membre de sa famille en fait c'est vrai
qu'au moment où il est revenu et qui m'a
montré ses photos du kayak de la
tyrolienne etc mais a tout de suite ça a
enlevé cette espèce de barrières
psychologiques ou moi je m'étais dit ok
quand on voyage il faut mon voyage dans
des villes pour être confort et pour
être ses choeurs est en fait en fait non
salar d'uyuni c'est le plus grand désert
de salomon c'est plus sympa et on a
lancé du coup une asso qui s'appelle
will want en 2018
le premier projet en fait ça a été de
dire ok on va se lancer dans un tour du
monde pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
voulait voir habran ou voulait se
prouver qu'on pouvait faire plein de
choses et c'est donc en amérique du sud
on est parti on a fait le machu picchu
donc là quand même pas mal de marche
enfin clermont star trek ont serré on va
pouvoir le faire nager avec des otaries
ont fait du kayak au pied d'un glacier
en argentine ont fait du surf et dans
des dunes de sable au pérou
et on fait on fait on fait la traversée
longue quand on aime ce qui est un
projet complètement fou on fait un peu
plus de 700 kilomètres ce qui est assez
assez fou c'est qu'on est vraiment
obligé de se coordonner puissance mille
et en fait ça c'est hyper important
parce que enfin faut avoir en tête que
le fauteuil de pierre ses jambes quoi
donc en groupe quand je l'aide c'est
comme si je prenais les jambes de
quelqu'un pour faire marcher je veux pas
que ce procès est ce que c'est moi qui
pousse pierre c'est moi qui ai choisi
l'itinéraire l'endroit où on passe etc
l'idée c'est de réussir à n'a été
interpellé hier à faire des trucs
ensemble
du coup en fait on a développé je pense
une empathie l'un envers l'autre qui est
quand même assez assez rare en fait on
est toujours obligé de se mettre à la
place de l'autre et je trouve que même
dans notre quotidien ça ajoute quand
même fin je pense que je comprends
beaucoup mieux et beaucoup plus
facilement que deux personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément des plus à quoi
et non mais j'aurais jamais pensé vivre
autant de choses par exemple un tour du
monde c'est quelque chose qui fait l
avais je pense beaucoup de gens mais je
me serais jamais faim je me serais pas
forcément dit tiens je vais partir sans
but précis
[Musique]
on dit plein de truc absolument dingue
aujourd'hui alors ouais enfin voila je
dis pas que c'est une bénédiction
d'avoir eu cet accident mais au final
lorsqu'on arrive à en faire je trouve
que c'est quand même un truc fait quoi
[Musique]